cette semaine dans un voyage presque
parfait ce sont cinq ambassadeurs de la
stricte
adrian david sabrina farah et guillaume
qui vont s'affronter
je t'ai bull d'enghien naussac wesh vont
s'inviter tour à tour dans leur terre
terre et au terme de chaque réseau à
chacun sera notée par ses gestes
c'est-y pas franchement la meuf étaient
des termes elle un petit vase il met
trois fous je pense que flinguer après
on est là tous convoitent le titre de
meilleur wesh de la semaine et la somme
de 1000 euros
mais surtout il aux gars et no go /
veulent prouver qu'ils ont la stricte
dans le sens horaire
ce soir c'est guillaume 25 ans chômeur
qui ouvre la battle son thème la galère
l'aes comme disent les jeunes
ça sonne aux pressions j'espère que
c'est pas une perquisition une dinguerie
la pac moi je m'attendais à un petit
crachin le mec c'est un petit joie
bourse
regarde là zhu zhu toi ça là ici là la
crédence tête de manière je suis sûr
c'est du mar
il m'a fait une bise est bienvenue c'est
cool sont cools j'aime bien ces gars là
voilà merci de venir mon humble demain
vous verrez j'ai fait une déco un peu
style damas un petit paul ancien type
orientaliste lourd
attendez je reviens ça peut coup c'est
abusé il a pris le respect il a tu es
allé l'apéro bâti munich bien à
l'ancienne allez allez faites par
virgile et farouche et bis mais la
moelle et back to qui se prennent pour
des airbus un pool samedi ouf on fait
table on s'arrête parler rebeu wesh moi
c'est pareil
ma mère est les berrichonnes sur un
quart corse un tas espagnol après cet
apéro plutôt maladroit
guillaume restent déterminés ils
décident enfin de passer à son dîner
voit donc comme le thème de la soirée
c'était la galère on est préparé des
kebabs ya tout mon frère sauce
algérienne chizick évita sauce barbecue
source kétamine qu'ils aient fait moi
même salade tomates oignons
comme d'habitude chef
j'aime pas les oignons ça fait puer de
la gueule
c'est un truc de ouf tu ne te la jouer
que gray tu prends les commandes les
kebabs à peu près terminée
guillaume propose maintenant son
animation surprise maintenant j'aimerais
en dessert un petite cerise sur le
ghetto proposer un petit freestyle drap
que j'ai composé - 9
ici c'est la misère match ici c'est la
galère je suis posé gentiment je tiens
les murs du bâtiment tabou c'est chaud
chaud crous tombe bien fin bien grèce
aux dédicaces
abdelkrim pour qui crachait par terre
c'était pas un crime ou frère qui a
craché par terre on attend son salon à
lui après cette animation plutôt
surprenante
guillaume décide enfin de passer au
dessert j'ai prévu un trip 2 ou un truc
de malade
un truc de venerque un gros - jeux wii
nick sa mère
et sa grand mère le frère voûte a cru
que je pète avait tu m'a regardé et m'a
pris pour qui en fait là vous n'avez pas
à vous mais n'avait pas dit walla walla
bédard mais si tu es tu en voilà
ah ouais j'aurais dû prévoir une chicha
posé là exactement c'est ça que tu
aurais dû faire bon et nous on taille
les gains fin des bye
tout le monde est prêt à s'arracher mais
découvre tout de suite et note que new
wave invités ont attribué à guillaume
j'espère vous avez passé une bonne
soirée lamée bilan le mec c'est un petit
rubin qui s'ajoute un constat c'est tout
il a cru que la stricte c'était les
clichés c'est pas bien tu fais pas ça
voilà du coup j'ai eu mes 4 c'était
chaud son prix style à retenir de rire
et tout bon allez je lui mets 5 la
moyenne parce que franchement il
et ils ont quoi fracas comme il est
juste b ghazi qui met 6 c'est quoi je te
mets deux dans ta mère allez je me casse
je garde le dise le rôti avec une
moyenne de 4 sur 10 guillaume est bien
parti pour rester en bonne hausse
il a bien entamé les hostilités
maintenant la battle est lancée demain
la révolte se passera chez adrian qui a
prévu comme thème le break dance 3 en
juin
ouais je sais lucia mensch huilage
déboule à la fin de la vidéo je suis là
pour dire abonne toi abonne toi je suis
sérieux sinon je te ballet et si tu veux
voir d'autres vidéos
c'est pas compliqué tu cliques tu fais
comme moi tu recharge ton gun est
d'accord tu ta bonne